david is in sacramento
hi david welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi
anthony how you guys doing doing well
how can we help
hi um so i'm on baby step two i have 2
000 in credit card debt
2500 in medical bills i just had a
second baby so that's where that's from
um i have exactly that amount in the
market in various stocks i was wondering
should i just
sell that now be totally debt free today
um
you know my income is about 120 a year
so i make good money i could pay off
events
uh relatively fast but would you
recommend that i just sell
you know that today or you know let the
money grow longer
while it's there now would you say these
are are these single stocks
yeah i just you know tesla and a couple
other companies yeah yeah i'ma sell
those go ahead and get out of them pay
off your debt
immediately okay asap okay here's the
reasoning right behind that then is
that all the data that we have from 30
years of doing this says the shortest
path to you becoming wealthy is not
playing single stocks while you have
money in debt
it is to become debt free manage your
budget
use the fact that you don't have any
payments anymore as you get on into baby
step four
to make more conservative investments
than you've made in good growth stock
mutual funds in your retirement and
begin
to grow that baby step five is do the
same thing with those mutual funds for
your kids college
instead of playing the market
out of all the millionaires that we
study
virtually i mean i would say as less
than five percent of them made their
money playing single stocks
95 of them did not use your methodology
yeah that's not something i thought i'd
be rich off of but i was more curious
what your recommendation was
i mean if you keep it so low in the
future that the amount of money is it's
a hobby
and then you lose it all that's fine 78
of the day traders lose money
yes okay so that just keep it i mean
it's like i've got
i don't gamble because i'm i i lose
money and i
and i work too hard for it so it bothers
me it's like a moral thing
for me it's a practical thing so i don't
get a thrill out of losing money at the
blackjack table it doesn't it doesn't
make me happy
but i've got a good friend who who makes
several million dollars a year and he'll
go lose a thousand dollars as his form
of entertainment i
ca that doesn't compute in my brain but
you could kind of put it in that
category if you want to play single
stocks
yeah and here's the thing too david now
once you pay off all your debt today i
mean once you sell your stocks and you
pay it off
and making 120 000 a year you'll be able
to get to your three months three to six
months within the
next four or five months and you'll be
right back to investing
so definitely make sure you check out
our smart investor pro so that way you
can get back to it
uh but i'm proud of you man yeah and get
back to mutual funds for you
you and your kids yes see if you're dead
free and you have an emergency fund
with with a second baby that's just so
much more important yes
than having this little bit of money
laying there in the market messing
around with
single stocks it's just it's so much
more important yeah
you would never borrow money to go do
that especially in your family situation
so that that's that's why we're giving
you this advice that's the why behind
the answer